Every once in a while, probably every two
months, we have a last minute guest cancelations,
sometimes they are the really immoral no call,
no shows. Today, our guest actually is just
feeling under the weather. So we're rescheduling
them. But the upside is I get to hear from some
of you instead via the dischord lines at David
Pakman dotcom slash discord. Let's go today to
Ron from South Carolina. Ron, what is going
on today? Hello, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Hey, David, I just wanted to say
I've been hearing a lot about the
about Georgia passing voting changes and I'm
not really sure what's going on with that.
How is that making voting harder?
Because I hear people say that a lot.
OK, yes. So Georgia and a number of other states,
so big picture Republicans didn't suppress enough
of the vote to win in November of twenty twenty.
So very shortly after Joe Biden was sworn in,
something like two hundred and fifty something,
various bills across more than 40 states were put
in place. And many of these make it more difficult
to vote by putting in place stricter voter ID
requirements, by limiting the number of places at
which people can vote by limiting voting hours.
And you can find, you know, the exact details of
every bill online. But that's the general idea.
And these are often tailored to none of these
bills are ever overtly written in a way that is
sort of classist or racist. But as we've
talked about before, you can fine tune and
disproportionately impact certain groups.
You can target poorer people, for example,
by making stricter ID requirements where to
get the ID. The ID itself is always free,
but to get the ID, you can put in place more
and more requirements for what documents you
need to show. Some of the required documents to
get the ID aren't free, and if you're poorer,
you may even have to take a day off from work
in order to go and pay for the document that you
need to get the ID. And that's how you can, for
example, disproportionately impact poor people.
And they're also making it, making it
illegal for people to hand out water
in these not really long lines.
Yeah, I that that I did look at that. I don't
understand the full exactly how that's written.
That broke while we were we were on break,
but I don't know if that's in an official
capacity. You can't hand out water or if
just nobody can give water to anybody else
that's in line. But yeah, I did read that.
OK, thank you, David.
All right, my pleasure. Thank you very much